um evening uh everyone
um look obviously it's been terminal and
time uh for the government but I think
the most important thing is to make sure
that people in this country uh know that
they've got security uh and that's why
it's a great honor to be appointed as
Home Secretary today I'm looking forward
to uh getting stuck into the wrong
hiding the the sort of security that the
British people need regardless of what's
Happening otherwise in in Westminster so
I'm looking forward to getting on with
the job and thank you for coming out
this evening thank you very much can
keep pledges has it and particularly on
migration well you'll forgive me I'm
literally you know 10 minutes into the
job so I'll I'll refrain for commenting
on the specifics of of the of this role
uh for the second but I mean look I
accept that the government has obviously
had a very difficult um period as Jeremy
Hunt said when he was appointed on on
Friday uh that nonetheless means it's
doubly important to ensure that we are
doing absolutely everything to in in the
basic areas and Jeremy Hunt I think it's
done a great job of settling uh the the
issues relating to that mini budget I
want to be here that the home office
doing I think one of the most important
roles in government and making sure that
people feel secure and protected and
that's what I'm going to do according to
grown up to mistakes and find that the
Prime Minister hasn't owed up to the
states well look uh you're probably an
advantage I haven't had a chance to
catch up with everything the previous uh
Home Secretary was saying what I do know
is there's a very important job to do uh
people expect their government to ensure
there is security for them the home
office is at the heart of that in so
many different ways it's a great office
of state I'm obviously honored to do
that role and I'm going to get on with
that serious role right now thank you
very much
thanks very much